jean-michel blanca se enfrenta a un
complicado regreso al trabajo tras las
vacaciones de navidad este martes el
medio de investigación mediapart reveló
que el ministro de educación de francia
estaba de vacaciones en ibiza mientras
daba a conocer el protocolo cobit de
vuelta a las aulas el día antes de que
las clases empezarán y a través de una
entrevista en el país jiang un medio de
pago las críticas han llegado desde todo
el abanico de la oposición
vuelvo a pedir que jean michel blanca
renuncia que el problema no es ibiza es
la inexperiencia de este ministro del
ministro sin embargo blanco cuenta con
el apoyo del gobierno del primer
ministro jan castex quien defiende que
los anuncios de último minuto no tienen
que ver con las vacaciones y que la
polémica es puro electoralismo de cara a
las presidenciales
blanquer ha estado muy presente estuvo
en la reunión de gobierno del 27 de
diciembre se tomó unos días de
vacaciones mientras esperábamos las
recomendaciones del consejo científico
por eso el protocolo tardó en colectar
dif
este argumento no convence a los
sindicatos de profesores franceses que
han convocado una nueva jornada de
huelga este jueves la comunidad
educativa ya salió a las calles la
semana pasada en protesta por los
cambios constantes de protocolos
sanitarios por la falta de personal
suplente y las carencias de material de
bioseguridad la nueva controversia
intensifica las tensiones y hace entrar
la inversión social y educativa en el
caldeado debate de las presidenciales de
abril